These fibers are made from old clothes.
It's part of a process that can turn nearly any used fabric into something brand new.
And fashion retailer H&M bets this solution...
...could eventually recycle some of the billions of tons of textile waste...
...produced every year.
But can a fast fashion company solve the problem it helped create?
We went to Hong Kong and Sweden to find out.
Most recycled textiles are turned into mattress stuffing or insulation.
And the original materials are scraps from the factory floor, not used clothing.
But this facility inside a Hong Kong shopping mall is the first in the world...
...to turn used clothes into new clothes all in one place.
First, a technician like Emily Shao examines the garment.
So today we'll recycle old garment.
This ozone chamber sanitizes the fabric in about an hour.
Then Emily removes the buttons, labels, and zippers.
And cuts the garment so the fabric is easy to work with.
The shredder strips the bits of cloth down further.
And then I would take off the open fabrics.
But this part of the process does require some new materials.
So we'll add some virgin fibers into the yarns to make the stronger.
Another machine mixes that cotton with the recycled skirt.
Emily then rolls the mixed fibers into clumps...
...and feeds them into a machine that turns them into what's called a fiber web.
But what happens next makes the assembly line in Hong Kong, the first of its kind.
The fiber web gets bundled into these snake-like slivers.
The slivers are then spun into ply yarn, the building blocks of a new garment.
Finally, a machine knits a new sweater based on a computer design.
Shoppers pay about $65 to recycle clothing here.